>>> THE WEST CLOSER TR
E REALIZE?
PHM MICHAEL SMERCONISH
A RUSSIA
VANGE SSLAND NEXT. PUTIN
QUOTE, FIRST PLAC
DENAZICATION RAINE, TS ST W CBR
TO DOUBLE ITS BORDER
IAION OFILAR
LIIN PD JU
AGO DURING A PHONE CALL AT
JOININULKETHAT CONVERSATION TAKT
THE NORDIC.
E U.S., E HOUS
TIONAL 4
MILITAID HAID FOR UKRAINE, BRIN
AMA'ORT FOR THFO NEARL54 BH NOYY
HUMANITARIOMS
EXPECTED TO PASS THE SE
EARLY NE WEEK BEFORE THE PNT'S O
THAT BILL ALG  LEAKS FROM N ADN
E UNITED
HAS BECE N UKRAINE., NEW YORK
REPORTEDR AMAN
INTELLIGENCE THAD IANS TO TAKEUR
CITED ANONS  OFFICIALS
ALSAI FLAGSHIP OF
THERE'S GROWING CONCERE U. IG
COULD TRIGGEUS NEXT GUEST RE-ENH
FEAR IN A RE
EDGING WAR AND IRE RUSSIA T
D R CO
WINOW TO DISCUSS IS THOMASS HRES
PRE HE NEW YORK RECENTLY
OF THE BEST ANK YOU
FOR BEINT GU
NIE CERTAINLY AT THE BIDENCK. CU
SINK ET S.LY HUN
N N
GENERATHEY'VE UNDERSTOOD IT'
REAL IA WAR TO Y GHT-FOCUSSED .
OUR OBJECTIVE IN THIS R IS TO
HELP UKRAINE LIBERE
CODEFENDTSDETHRE, NOTHING LESS.
ASONHAT,
OF BOTH THMESTICORT FOR THE WARA
AWAY FRO, TALKE GLOBALLY.E DR
TAKING DOWN  ECETERA,
YOU START TOY THE
AL
>> OKAY.I'GL SAID THAT
USI STRUGGLE T
AN MIGARE TOO MUCH T
GENERALS
ON THURSDAY, I'LL G D I' R
, TOM.N POSTFOLLOWING, TSA T
ADIDANCE AROUND INTELLIGENCE
AVOID HEIGHTENIONS N WASHINGTON
GIVEE PERSAT LEVEL, THE
PROHI BIGS KINDS
D ATRMATION THAT THE UD  CAN SU.
PROVIDILED IMA
RUSSIAN LEADERSHIP F SUCH
SE C PHITELLIGENCE SNG
OULD HELATAN E UKRAINE'E E GUAR
MICHAEL, TO THOSLEAKTO
MAKE I EONAT OURHICH IS, AGAINHR
OULD THE
DIY SSARIMM RA WAR, TO SUPPORT
THAT.IN NOON
K THE ADMINISTRATION G
MESSAGE
SE E. IN, THE
ADMIE GOTTEN
E T LOOS
SINK SHIPST NEVERTHELESS,
BEING -- LOOK  T0 BILLIO
SOTHE 40 IN D THAT WILL W  FORTG
WE DO OTHER
PSGROU
I  THAT
I SURE WLDGERING. T
EXACTLY WHATOE IT.
WHAT AREALLY PROHERE.
INK TA
THDON'T THTHD JO B
THESE CATS TOGETHER OF TS  THEMD
ING IT BORDE NDING,
LEU
.
S WHICH
YOU E EXELY,HERE SOME LA
AND DOES THE PRESIDENT DESERVE T
CR REGARD?
YEAH.
PRESIDENT BILLED PRESIDENT
VET IFHADN'T
DONE THE MATH, BIDEN WOULD D
E CHINA'S TWRT MARKETSHE
AND SHOULD CHINA
MAETINK THCHINESE MATH.INK ALSO
THAT PUTIN WAS LOSING, I
THEY ALSO DI'TE TO B
HIS SI
THE CHINESE HANOUGH TROUBL
THEY'RGH WITH MOTR E VI
NGHEY NEEDED WAS
TO GET EILL
MILITARY CONFLICT OPE.>> TOM, A
MENTIO RUSANBER WA P
G LABORING OR
THE REFUGEE
US FARUGHTS MIGHT YOU
ABOUT POLAND'S R
>> IYOIS
'S VERY IMPORT.
ALL -- FOR A LOT OF TH AWAALLYEO
EQPMOTLL
IFE PUTIN, HADWRITTEN THISARS HD
Y CHALLENGE NATO
ACTUALLY LIVE UPS ARTIE
THENT THAT
SAYS EVERY MELP BES
ATTACKED.
D T OF IES THAT AREPYO
PROVIDE MATERIAL SUPPORT TT MIL.
RYY MUCH TRY MOVE WOULD T BE A B
TOK POLA
AND SAY HEOPLE
ARE YOU RETOE
I ATTORYGLAD YAIIT.
WELLKES ME NERVOUS.
LET'S GOACK TO W
E CONGRESS NWEY
THE RETURN OD AND
JONY DEPP.
HOW NESH
TODAE SHE VERY
NED.
AND I THINI OK
N MIAEDI
WHERE, YOU KNOW, YOU DON'TM THBE
I THINK IT IY BE
DRIVEN BACK TOHETRY NN COUNTRY